das war ein ungewöhnlicher auftritt von
annegret kramp-karrenbauer der
cdu-vorsitzenden hier nach den
gremiensitzungen der partei in diesen
sitzungen wurde über den ausgang der
wahl in thüringen am sonntag beraten und
die cdu hat bekanntlich bei der wahl der
schlecht abgeschnitten
ange kam karrenbauer ging in eine art
vorne verteidigung sie sagte wer jetzt
die führungsfrage stellen
er hat auf dem bundesparteitag dazu die
gelegenheit das zielte auf eine äußerung
des jungen vorsitzenden kuban der in der
sitzung eben diese führungsfrage
angesprochen hatte ohne aber schon
präziser zu werden kam karrenbauers
entgegnen sie wurde von teilnehmern
berichtet sei sehr entschlossen gewesen
es sei die einzige äußerung zum thema
führungsfrage durch kramp karrenbauer
gewesen und trotzdem auch wenn dieses
feuerchen schnell ausgetreten werden
konnte
so ist es doch ein tag mit schwierigen
diskussionen gewesen denn für die cdu
stellt sich nach der wahl die frage wie
weit gehen wir in gesprächen mit der
linkspartei als spitzenkandidat mohring
der mehr als 11 prozentpunkte verloren
hat bei der wahl heute morgen auch nur
ansatzweise andeutet er bereits zu
stehen für gespräche
natürlich führe ich die mit dem
ministerpräsidenten dieses landes für
sich mit der parteivorsitzenden der
linken euch für sie mit dem
ministerpräsidenten und ich finde dass
selbst treten und verantwortlich für das
land sorgte das sofort für empörung die
cdu hat sich seit langem festgelegt
keine koalition keine zusammenarbeit mit
der linkspartei
plötzlich schien dieses infrage gestellt
zu sein hier auf der pressekonferenz von
mohring neben kramp karrenbauer stand
hat etwa auch deutlich gemacht
dass er sich an die beschlusslage der
partei halte aber genauso hat ja gesagt
er werde mit ramelow sprechen sollte
dieser gespräche anbieten eine
realisierung zur irgendwelche samt keine
priorisierung für irgendwelche koalition
oder verkündung aber es ist die frage
welchen schritt geht man selbst zuerst
und ich finde wenn die cdu sich all dem
verweigern würde dann würde sich ihrer
verantwortung nicht zurechtkommen jetzt
scheint man zeit gewinnen zu wollen nach
dem motto soll ramelow erstmal kommen
dann reden wir das gebietet sozusagen
die staatspolitische verantwortung und
alles was dann kommt werde man dann
sehen viele in der cdu hoffen und setzen
darauf dass ist nicht zu einer
zusammenarbeit zwischen ihrer partei und
der linken kommt ich kann für die cdu
noch mal sagen wir sind gestern
eindeutig nicht als erster sieger durchs
ziel gegangen was wir sehr bedauern
und deswegen liegt die frage wie eine
mögliche regierung in thüringen aussehen
kann jetzt vor allen dingen in den
händen des zurzeit amtierenden
ministerpräsidenten